House Republicans push back today's
planned release of their sweeping tax
overhaul after meeting last night to
work on some changes they hope to make
the plan public tomorrow one day before
President Trump leaves on a trip to Asia
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with that story Margaret good morning
good morning well the Trump White House
had hoped to focus this week on selling
that Republican tax plan but events of
the past 48 hours have made that
challenging now tax reform is one of the
few unifying issues for the Republican
Party but GOP lawmakers have yet to
agree on key details which has pushed
today's expected rollout to tomorrow
President Trump tweeted last night that
Republican House members are working
hard and White House chief of staff John
Kelly struck an optimistic tone telling
CBS News that a one-day delay won't
matter because he thinks everybody knows
it's gonna pass well the President does
need a legislative victory but public
opinion may not be on his side in the
latest CBS News poll seven out of ten
Americans said other issues should take
priority over tax cuts and nearly 60
percent thought the wealthy and large
corporations should have their taxes
increased instead of that 20 percent cut
favored by the president now in order to
sell this
he cabinet members will be staying here
in Washington instead of traveling to
Asia with the president and his daughter
Ivanka Trump will be Criss crossing the
country trying to sell this proposal
charlie
thanks Margaret